if a feminist sees you holding that sign
she'll come over and punch you in the
face to tell you how innocent she is
okay
so be careful okay so so i think i think
feminism is a hate group i think they
actually hate men i don't think it's
about equality i think in 2022 as a
woman i have nothing to fight for today
this is my opinion i'd love to hear what
yours is right
what you're feeling
is true okay
okay
feminism has been changed and corrupted
but so has people
positives whisper negatives shout
so we tend to see negatives first so no
matter which group you're in
negatives will always be prominent in
your head so when you look around the
world all you see is that's negative
that's negative
whatever whatever whatever so you live
in a world of negativity
and that makes people angry
and that leads to height and other
things so why do you think that is why
do you think um as women we focus on um
like the hate rather because we live in
the freest societies ever in history
there are two motivational forces
survival reproduction
survival fear negative get away from me
love positive come towards me okay
positive negative it's very simple but
we twist we love what we fear fear what
we love
and we twist
by nature everything twists the earth
goes around the sun blah blah blah
so so negative shout
beauty whispers they both talk
simultaneously so we always hear the
negative the shout over the whisper
but the whisper's always there if you've
got faith and hope then the whisper's
always there if you haven't because the
shouting is so loud then everything is
darkness black negativity anger height
what would you like to see from feminism
like in the future
from everyone
because if we're talking equality from
everyone because feminists don't
actually want equality they just want
equality when it benefits us i was born
in 67 summer of love i was raised
through the bra burning and the
independent woman and
right
and
i've always been raised by strong women
i got my testicles from my father but
i've got my bollocks from my mum
yeah
yeah yeah no no i agree i think like
like so being passionate and having
strength and tenacity shouldn't be a bad
thing yet it is looked upon as a bad
thing now because it's a more sheep-like
environment so the people that are more
fearful worried hateful negative stand
out more
in a peaceful crowd than they would do
when everyone's lively yeah no i don't
think it's the i don't even think the
majority of women are feminists to be
honest the most women i know like don't
identify as a feminist because that that
group has
is like they're just so man-hating like
i love men i grew up around brothers
okay
um
some people
uh want to be dominated
right on one level uh but then hate
themselves on another level
and they build up their own internal
battle
their own yin yang
negatives tend to win
unfortunately
well thank you for coming by i
appreciate it i appreciate it i needed
someone to get the ball rolling so this
is great
thank you
the problems are larger yeah humanity
yeah i agree
to each other look at what we do to the
planet look at what we do to ourselves
what was your name and do you have any
links you want to plug do you have any
like instagram youtube
jason human
okay okay thank you all right be well
good luck bye what a nice man see that
that's the type of guy i'm looking for
to sit down have a nice civil
conversation so what's your name gloria
i'm pearl nice to meet you
so um i think feminism is a hate group
because i think that it tears down men
and i i think they just advocate for
women and they advocate for women at the
cost of men okay so you think it's
detrimental to women nowadays
i think i think it's always been
detrimental
um okay and the reason being like they
push things like the pay gap when the
pay gap doesn't even exist
for women so they're they're actively
tearing down men to like build women up
and what do you think about like the
household situations
households so right now in the current
times a lot more women are independent
and then i've i've read somewhere that
they're saying that um
feminism is destroying actual the
household because it's making more women
be more independent i think there's
something about men becoming redundant
but i just like to gather information
well i just think it lies to women
because it tells us to like chase a bag
and you know chase a career don't
prioritize family and then we end up
single childless and alone
and i think they do that at the cost of
men like most feminists i know they
don't they just they disdain that so
like what about this new movement i have
him not hyper megan but like the um
what's it called again
what's this thing that we're
leveling up
leveling up yes
what do you mean by leveling up so women
are now
we've been told to go and get men who
are more high high net worth high level
so they can be
treated have a soft life
treated better not chase the bag like
financially take care of the home
what do you think of that because that
i've read is that that's more against
feminism because i was reading something
that said feminism is detrimental to
women as well
so women need to go back to how it was
um i think people should be free to
choose what they wanna i feel like they
should be free to choose what they want
to choose
but um i i think when you go when you
tell women to make a lot of money and
then only go after men that make more
money than you it leaves you as a side
piece
because
what percentage of men make uh six
figures do you think not a lot i think
it's less than like because the average
in the uk is 36 000 36 something so how
much men they actually make unless
they're in like big cities like london
and stuff like that yeah yeah so
feminism is telling you to like chase
this career
when
like and then
you're gonna have a guy waiting for you
at the end of it but men aren't
attracted to that
so can i ask you a question so what
would you say people are like you're
just being like you have internalized
misogyny
[Music]
people do say that a lot um
and i would say that most people that
say that like have a victim mindset
where they just think the world is
against them and i think as a woman i'm
at an advantage rather than a
disadvantage that is very interesting
yeah no i love talking to you well i've
gotta go sorry for my sister oh no
that's okay thank you but no we're
sitting down
do you have any like any socials you
wanna tag yeah
instagram yeah follow me
hot guys
hot guys hotties
it's glory love89
are you a feminist
do you know what yeah i think to be
honest i'm a meist
so what's most beneficial for me
that is what i am
so i'm not going to say i have not used
my own privileges to help me get certain
things yes i have okay
i've been the damsel in distress many
times but then i'm like no go women so
i'm a mest
you so much you're such a good sport
yeah she was chill i liked her okay what
do you think of feminism
it's really i don't know it's i think
it's made to just break man's balls if
you allow me to say excuse my language
but
i don't believe there is such a thing as
feminism